Kanye's whole thing is I don't give a
[ __ ] art is something that you would
really fight for if you love it even if
your message is misunderstood like white
lives matter he's an artist that likes
War
one of the founders of Rockefeller
Rockaway he discovered Jay-Z Kanye West
and so many others one of the biggest
Pioneers in hip-hop I took Jay-Z and
shocked him to every single label and
they all said no I had to do it myself I
really want to understand why
Rockefeller won I did Partnerships with
my artists I'm gonna give you all the
rights to my record my art and then
you're gonna give me 10 of my art that
just didn't make sense to me that host
end of your career the Rockefeller
chapter
do you have any regrets surrounding that
one I wouldn't I wouldn't have been so
generous with Jay it was more friendship
for me and money for him but he did
things that I thought he would never do
what are those I'm just saying this let
me just say this
it's the hardest moment in your life
well I'll hear that
that breaks my heart
singer actress Aaliyah is killed in a
plane crash I tried to play out what
that would feel like don't do it you
don't want you don't want to go there
it's a it's a pain that you don't
couldn't understand
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I just want to say a huge thank you to
all of our new subscribers
74 of you that watch this channel didn't
subscribe before and we're now down to
about 71 so that helps us in a number of
ways that are quite hard to explain but
simply the bigger the channel gets the
bigger the guests get so if you haven't
yet subscribed to the Diary of a CEO if
I can have any favors from you if you've
ever watched this show and enjoyed it
it's just to please hit the Subscribe
button without further Ado I'm Stephen
Butler and this is the Diary of a CEO I
hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this yourself
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I always believe that in order to
understand a man you have to understand
their earliest context because as
childhood psychology often asserts
that's really when
um our character and our our shape is
formed so can you take me back to your
earliest context the context that's most
relevant to who you went on to become in
your life back in Harlem
um on 109th and First Street
my first like real memory of who I am is
I remember being like four
and I was in Nursery School
and the teacher yelled at me
or I got in trouble
and I felt embarrassed
I felt uncomfortable
and I remember saying to myself at as a
four-year-old I'm never going to feel
embarrassed again
ever I didn't like the way it felt you
know like when Fred Flintstone used to
get yelled at and he started shrinking
and I just was like I'm never going to
put myself in a position to let any
adult teacher whatever
I'm never going to be embarrassed I just
hated that I remember not liking that
feeling and I think that was the last
time I felt it
pause
and how did that so that presumably
impacts your relationship with authority
figures it just means I don't care what
anybody thinks
so no matter what regardless to what
you're not going to make me feel as less
of who I am I know who I am so there was
no way that teacher was going to make me
feel small just because they were a
teacher and I was a student there was no
way that they were going to make me feel
less of myself I was never going to let
another person make me feel bad about
myself ever again the last time that
happened I was four years old but what I
saw was as I got older that this is the
way people live their life fear what
people think of them and that's the
reason why they don't say what they feel
that's the reason why they internalize
and that's the reason why they end up
depressed so as long as you're
expressing yourself as long as you don't
care as long as you're not hurting
anybody there's no pain to feel it's
almost like at that point I sprayed this
thing called I don't give a [ __ ] what
anybody's thinking spray and I think
that's been the most important thing is
not to care about the Judgment of other
people
what about your parents could they tell
you
what to do
well
my of course as a child but my mom died
when I was 16 so I was still a child so
at that point I was making money you
know the last time anyone could tell me
what to do would be the last time
someone was paying my bills so if you
paying my bills then you could tell me
what to do and I've never put myself in
a situation like that as an adult for
someone to be able to tell me what to do
they could give me advice
my parents could give me advice but you
know at 16 or 17 after my mom died I was
getting more money than my dad
you know so at that point it's hard to
listen to people that are older than you
that hasn't that haven't got to the
place you want to go and as a child you
become very arrogant when you can do
adult things
but my mother was the one that taught me
to never ever
let someone tell you something that you
don't believe without saying how you
feel about it
and you know almost where made it to
where we might have had almost a
somewhat disrespectful relationship
because I would talk back
but you know in school I would talk back
if I didn't agree with you I was letting
you know
and I'd be like my mother taught me that
you know what I mean
so I was basically taught to talk back
you're a father now when you when you
look back yeah yeah I should be a
grandfather I just you know I just my
last my newest child uh uh you know I
met I had it 150. I'm 51.
five kids
yeah last time I counted when you look
back on
um your own relationship with your
parents and how now that you're you know
you're a father you've got kids of your
own how in hindsight did that shape you
the relation to the dynamic between your
parents but also their relationship with
you is there anything you look back and
say well because of that I became this
oh everything I have a tattoo on my arm
that says thanks for making me the man I
am so yeah I got my sense of humor from
my father and I got my hustle from my
mother
period and yeah you become a combination
of the people that influence you the
most that's why you have to be important
I mean it's important that you're
cognizant of what you do when you
realize that people are actually
influenced by you you know what I mean
you never want to do something that you
don't want the people you love to do
because they're going to do exactly what
you do
so I got a little bit of that you know
my mom she was like you know an
entrepreneur she always made sure I had
everything she sold things you know I
mean not drugs but like you know like uh
clothes
you know what I mean but like at flea
markets and stuff and she was real
Innovative about it
she did this thing once he went to a
flea market and she took a hula hoop and
put a curtain on it and we would stand
up and it made into a dressing room and
that day she sold all of her jeans she
made 800 that day I remember at aqueduct
so you know I've always had that hustle
and bustle for my moms and and and and
doing things different
at an early age made me know that that's
the only way you could do it right like
standing in like if you don't stand out
then you're just atmosphere in a crowd
but when you do things different than
people are drawn to
one of the things I've thought about
since growing up is how a lot of the
things that I value most as
characteristics of myself probably came
from what the world would consider to be
mistakes that my parents made so one of
them being like not being around me
makes you independent or you know
maybe being a workaholic maybe makes the
kid a workaholic or maybe not having
money gives you drive when you think
about
the things that wouldn't be in that like
parenting Handbook of how to raise a
child that ultimately served you
and made you you know the man you are
today is there anything there where you
go a mistake made me brilliant
yeah
every mistake that I had to fix made me
bring it make sure boss because that's a
boss's job is to like untie knots
um
you know your job as a parent
is to make sure your children never have
to go through the same problems that you
went through is to break Cycles But
first you kind of have to understand
what that cycle is so as an adult that
had children I was you know I ain't
gonna like [ __ ] on my dad but
if I were him I would have been in my
life a little more
and you can look at a like you know
there's this thing like you know if your
father's an alcoholic you could either
become an alcoholic because of it or
just never touch drinks it depends on
how things affect you so
you know the way he parented and the way
I knew and I was conscious about the way
it made me feel I knew what not to do to
my children or what not to you know be
absent or how when I should be
consistent
you know the cycle that I've wanted to
break was that cycle where
you know your mother tells you not to
like your father and your father's
telling you certain things about your
mother and those are the people that you
love the most and only thing you want as
a child is for your parents to get
together that's all you want so you know
it took me to have five kids to have a a
good
um
relationship
a good um
you know one that's not so traumatizing
for the child a functional relationship
it took me five to to be fifty to get
there but each one of those children the
other four children I knew that I was
like damn I I you know even though I've
been able to make it where they've never
had to sell drugs and they've had the
best educations and lived that one
percent of life but I I wasn't able to
break that cycle the thing that hurt me
the most was the separation of my
parents and the beef I wasn't able to
break that cycle so
you know I I wasn't gonna stop till I
did it was almost like with every child
I became a better parent but knowing
that the breakup of my mother and father
affected my mother for the rest of her
life which affected me
you know what I'm saying and I didn't
want to ever do that to my to my um to
my children and then also being a
visiting dad is whack
you want to wake up with your child you
want to watch your child grow and evolve
you know buying and and providing
physical things a kid doesn't even care
about that that's not currency to a kid
they don't even know about money until
you tell them about it
all they care about is your time
and that's the most valuable thing is
you know the love that you can give your
child
so you know at some point you might
think okay I'll sacrifice time with my
child because I got to make money to
support them
but the kid don't care about that
you know the kid just wants you to be
there
to support him did you learn did you
learn about emotions and affection and
how to express yourself from from your
parents was that was that something that
you were able to do as a young man well
yeah I mean I wouldn't put a title on it
like oh this is affection but I've
always been able to express myself in
any way
you know whether I'm crying or whether
I'm cuddling
you know I don't have any uh problems
about being and showing what I feel in
that moment
unless it's the police
you you'll you're 16 16 years old when
your mother passes away um
yeah
how does how does that change you from
everything I've read about that time in
your life she was
she was everything and I read that you'd
said that that was your biggest fear
when you were a young man was losing
your mother yeah
yeah it made me a beast it made me feel
this you know it's like a gift in the
curse
of facing your nightmares early because
then you have nothing else to be scared
of
so you know my mom's died
again I didn't really care
if I die because I'd be like oh should I
I'd be with my moms so I didn't I had no
fear of anything at that point and I
knew how I would react
you know because sometimes you you don't
know how you're going to react in
certain situations so I knew how how I
could get over it not get over it but
live with it
and also it makes you appreciate what a
real problem is you know like
you know like after my mom's died I was
like yo nobody's dying I don't even want
to hear about it it could be fixed I'm
not gonna ever be unhappy
unless it has something to do with
Health death or freedom
you know what I'm saying but other than
that nothing's gonna ever make me worry
like I'm not going to be like a lot of
people overreact to problems because
they never had any they don't know what
a problem is and they make something
that's like feel like it's the worst
thing in the world
and I'm not gonna ever do that because I
appreciate when things are good
you know I'm saying it'd be like just in
any second some [ __ ] could happen that's
[ __ ] up so in between those moments
that you can't control you have to enjoy
life to the fullest
100 but sometimes you have to actually
go through some pain early so you
understand how to appreciate life moving
forward same thing of me losing my girl
losing Aaliyah
you know
it wasn't a pain I thought that I would
ever feel of you know you don't
anticipate like losing your girl but
once you do you once you get a girl
again you don't let go and you
appreciate love
you know [ __ ] has to be taken from you
things things that are free you find are
Priceless when they get taken from like
freedom and people you love
you know and then you're like what was I
complaining about you know I was rich I
was wealthy because I had love and now I
don't and there's no money in the world
I could bring it back
you know once your health is gone
it don't matter you will spend any
amount of money to get your health back
if you're sitting in the bed compromised
once your freedom is taken
you'll spend any amount of money to get
out of jail all of it because you can't
spend none of it while you're in jail
other than on commissary which is
and then again lose a friend lose
someone you love you'll do you if you
could do any you'd spend anything in the
world to get that person back
but then you have to actually lose them
to realize how much and how how lucky
you were to have them so I try to
appreciate life in the moment
I do appreciate life in the moment
because I'll be like what if this was
taken from me then I'd be sick
you know 16 years old losing your mum in
that context in Harlem
how do you how do you how do you grieve
that nobody teaches you how to grieve
you sell drugs sell drugs yeah
that's how I grieved that was like yo
I'm gonna go get money you know what I'm
saying and you know at at that point in
that moment I thought because I was
younger that money
meant happiness
so I would do anything for it in that
moment you know I mean like you know I
was selling drugs I was risking my
freedom
and my life and hurting other people
so that's how I did it you know just
occupying my time and moving forward
period it's not it's not grieving or is
that a distraction I don't know what you
call it at that age it's called and
getting through it so yeah it's probably
a distraction
you know but again like what did you
want to do at 16.
to me
you know I didn't have the money for a
therapist or the hindsight to go get one
in that moment
so I just sold drugs is that what you
think in hindsight you needed if I
didn't mean anything I like where I'm at
now I think every lesson that I've
learned to get me to this place has been
perfect for me and for the world the
world learns as I learn
that's the guy that I've become
I don't call them losses I call them
learning experiences but when you do
that publicly and you could always land
or you always land back on your feet the
rest of the world learns from that
Tim Grover who um trained MJ and Kobe
said to me that you know you're looking
to people's early years and you'll find
you'll find trauma and things that have
happened in pain and it will be the
often be responsible for their as he
called it their Light Side the thing
that makes them great and famous and
resilient and successful and win the
gold medals but then that that thing is
also responsible for their dark side
which can be the you know it can be the
insecurities it can be the the things
that are less um admired do you agree
with that and if so
um what is your dark side
well
you know I think it's natural to be
worried when things are going good for a
second because it's happened where
things are going good and I've been
devastated but in that moment I say it's
normal for you to think like that you've
been through it
I think the only dark side is people
triggering me that you know
when I feel someone's not doing right by
me
or by people that I love
I I can get triggered pretty I get
triggered
it's hard to control that side
why why can you get easily triggered
I probably because I've there's been
things that have been bothering me
for a while
you know when you're in the street you
have to make examples of people
so any kind of weakness means that more
people are it makes you like a magnet
for paint like people trying to rob you
or think you saw for whatever
especially when you run a crew you know
so you always have to be the strongest
you have to be willing to do anything
that you're sending someone else to do
you know what I'm saying so in the
street you know it's it's swing now
think about it later it's survival mode
and what happens is just because you're
out of survival mode your muscles and
your Natural Instincts still do survival
mode at times so I've had to get therapy
to you know be like yo you're not in the
street to be able to say that like yo
you're not in the street so you don't
have to deal with things that way
anymore
but if you've seen in my career you know
it'd be a lot of yelling because I would
rather put like when I'm really yelling
it would be me like in the street out of
put my hands on you so instead of me
yelling
I mean instead of me putting my hands on
you and going to jail I would just yell
or snap
so I had to actually because it's a
different game in the street than it is
in business
and the rules are different like you
know being disrespectful is almost part
of like traditional corporate business
the [ __ ] that you do every day in
corporate business we could get you put
in a trunk in the street
and if you come from the street and you
have to be like oh that hurt like I
would have really I can't hurt you I
can't hit you I can't do nothing I can't
defend myself I got to go through a
lawyer for this
it could become traumatized and you got
to internalize a lot so disrespect
triggers me
and you know people trying to
control a narrative by tricking you into
thinking you're not great when you
really are you know I mean people have
tried to convince me I'm not a superhero
and I know I am
I'm Batman
why is that an important belief for you
because I'm always fighting for the
culture that's what a superhero does
you know or general
like you know back in the Roman days no
matter how much money you had you were
not famous unless you fought for your
country and won a war for your country
for something you love
you know and for me I'm a person that
loves a lot not just country I Love
Culture I love a lot I love art there's
so much for me to fight for
you know what I'm saying it's like I
just can't look the other way
for things that affect me and my culture
and things that people I love it's hard
I think a lot of conditioning happens
when you see things are wrong and you
got to look the other way for survival
and I've just never been that guy and I
don't come from a family or a bloodline
of people that have ever been abused
that have ever been bullied I come from
a bloodline of people that bully the
bully that oppressed the oppressor like
we look for people that think they're
tough because we really think they are
not just based on the overcompensation
you know what I mean
so it's not in how you like project
project yourself or act it's really
about what you do
if I lost you when you were 16 17 after
your mother passes what you're going to
be when you're older I just said great
I'm gonna be great I'm gonna be Dame
Dash
I didn't know what I was gonna be
at 16 I just knew I was going to be
great
how could you be so sure
how could you not be so sure I'm Dame
Dash you know what I'm saying like my
narrative's never been losing you know
when you start out winning
and that's all you know even when it
appears you lose if you're a winner
you're like I could I just can't see
myself losing
so no matter what it's gonna I'm gonna
end up winning I'll learn from it it'll
be be patient but I just don't see I
don't see losing you realize that not
everybody has that mindset right just
too bad for them
I don't understand why
do you understand where you got that
mindset from I'm from Harlem it's just a
harlem thing I think my family
you know and just winning like you know
being that kid in school that was like
good at all the sports Becca fight could
dance funny
you know what I mean
I just don't see myself taking a hell
that belief has not
built built over time like got stronger
and reinforced by success over over and
over again like building like this
building of evidence about what you're
capable of and who you are
has it developed or was it just always
solid I just never thought I wasn't
gonna win like I I don't know I mean
like for someone to ask me and say like
that's crazy that you always think
you're gonna win I really think that's
crazy that you don't think you're always
gonna win like the way I see the
opposite I just don't understand why I
get into a fight that you think you're
gonna lose and life is a fight every day
so why would I get into anything
thinking I'm not going to make history
I'm like a little behind schedule for me
right now
what do you mean by that
well
again in the beginning of my career
everything I did was for money I was all
about the money
and then this thing happened where it
just became all about the art
and being able to sustain doing what I
want being happy and being able to
create
becoming a starving artist and just
being someone that not exploits artists
but actually is the artist I was doing
it the business way and I was getting
where I needed to go as far as touching
pop culture but the people around me
were making it where I wasn't happy
about it didn't feel good
and I decided to do it the artist's way
so back then I didn't know I would be
like [ __ ] I just want to be an artist
I thought if I was just doing things for
money like imagine would I be in the
music business right now if I just was
like exploiting everyone that's not
smart
you know and taking advantage like if I
took advantage of Jay-Z which I probably
could
he didn't know anything about the
business
he might try to act like that now but I
trust you know what I'm saying so you
know
if I was that person that would do
anything no Integrity no morals or
Scruples I'd have billions and billions
and billions of dollars I wouldn't have
taught my artists how to leverage their
celebrity for their own products I would
just leverage their celebrity for my own
you're gonna say I don't I like I teach
my artists how to be independent of me
you understand what I'm saying that's
why the artist around me end up like
usually it's the businessman that has
more money than artists right the
artists are the ones that have more
money than the business man obviously
I'm not the businessman you know what
I'm saying I once I have the bread I'm
the artist it's funny how artists become
businessmen they kick the heart at
certain points
or who's really an artist or what a real
artist is but to me a real artist is
someone that won't do nothing for money
which is me I won't do nothing for money
I make money off the things that I love
to do
of the art and I respect the process of
Art
you feel me that's why you see when I
came in I I know it's I know the process
but not of one art of a lot so I know
the fashion art the music art the comic
you know even though I don't draw but
you know all of these different things I
tried I learned them from to where I
could do it independently and I don't
have to Outsource
at the cost of the timeline which could
have been you're saying could have been
faster if you if you chosen to exploit
people right
and that's a trade-off that a lot of
people
wouldn't have taken they would have
taken yeah that's funny measurable yeah
they're on pills
now they're not happy now they're paying
for sex it's just I won't do it
for the first part of your career you
were
you were on the other side right you
were the businessman you were you were
working with artists like Jay-Z and
Kanye and many many others
um and you weren't in sort of artist
mode as you kind of see yourself now
with the comic books and the movies and
the music and everything else you're
doing everything you're doing children's
books the the list was so long that I I
thought just it's almost it's like I
said it's Insanity it's ridiculousness
the amount of things that inspire me
that I think I could actually do better
than everyone else
when you look back though on that and
that period from you know from being
that 16 year old you go through school I
heard you got kicked out of school a lot
okay I got kicked out of one school and
then I dropped out of the next but
um you got kicked out a lot of schools I
can understand why from what you said
about that four-year-old kid that why
would I want somebody that doesn't have
as much money as I want to make trying
to tell me what to do
and how you think they felt when I would
tell them that like my car is better
than yours I'm 16. you're the principal
you know what I'm saying then you park
in the principal spot one time as well
that's what got me kicked out of two
schools
it's so crazy because you know
there would be kids at the real wild
stuff in school that did not get kicked
out but question this entitlement of
certain kinds of people
just because someone gives them
Authority doesn't mean I'm acknowledging
it
that Journey that led you from there
from being kicked out of that school to
you know signing Jay-Z building that
career and all of that success around
Jay-Z and Kenny what was when you look
back at why you why you versus everyone
else what did you have to to spot
Jay-Z's talent to spot Kanye's talent to
build them into stars to create
Rockefeller alongside them what was it
about you in hindsight the
characteristics of you as a person that
made you capable of doing such an
endeavor
I mean I just wasn't taking no like if I
believe someone's gonna win I'm 100 sure
that they will
and then I fight and make sure that they
do did you have history and music before
Jay's I mean you've done you
've been together music business yeah I
got to be I was in the music since I was
19. so I went from drug dealing to the
music business
do you need any qualifications to join
to become part of the music business no
you could be the dumbest [ __ ] in
the world that's why so many people that
really
you see I mean in the music business the
traditional music business they are
figureheads that like if you ask the
average president of a you know label
about p l and quarterly you know they
won't know [ __ ] about that they're just
there because a white company or another
culture can't say that they're running
black people with a white face so you
need a figurehead there
someone that will listen to what that
person is telling them what to do
and that's why that industry was no
bueno for me I'm like first of all I
never got hired in that industry I came
as a partner but the funny thing is they
couldn't recognize me as a partner
because they were not and I couldn't
recognize them as generals they'd be
like yo how are you going to talk to
you're a soldier how could you talk to a
general like that without thinking your
teeth are going to get cracked
you understand what I'm saying
and they didn't understand that like you
don't understand I own this [ __ ] you
work for somebody
talk to me like the boss and it's crazy
how you will talk to the people that
don't own [ __ ] like the boss
they just couldn't understand what that
meant to own my actual Equity the own
have ownership not had sell my rights to
something and then let somebody else pay
me for my work that does not logically
make sense and it never did to me you
know what that means like you have a
grown ass man saying and being proud to
say I'm signed
does that actually sound right I'm
signed to another man
no it doesn't but they've actually
programmed us to believe it is you're
going to give me an advance I'm gonna
give you all the rights to my record my
everything that I've done my art and
then you're going to give me 10 of my
art
that's what the music business is or
eight percent if you're lucky
that just didn't make sense to me and I
never did I did Partnerships with my
artist with the artists I work with in
the businesses that I do now
just because I want people to maintain
their manhood
like I don't ever say you signed to me
I'm I'm not letting I don't like the way
that sounds
so
you know even the verbiage in the the
whole thing just your masters
you know what I'm saying all of those
things are like trigger words you know
they're unconsciously control us
can we smoke here if you want it yes is
this I don't know is that a fire alarm
didn't know
you're not even from here man I have no
idea don't even get out of here that's
just you just you just we're not in the
hotel okay is it is it gonna go off
because you think we'll go up I have no
idea what that is it should be fine it
is what it is it is what it is you know
I'm trying to I really want to
understand why Rockefeller won and you
know it's because it was real because it
was real it was real and I wasn't having
it
Rocco they weren't no one wanted to sign
think about how this is the record
industry
I took Jay-Z and shocked him to every
single label and they all said no I had
to do it myself where did they send her
either he was too old he raped too fast
they just didn't have it
so we were like we'll do it ourselves so
that's the thing remember when I said
before people been telling me I'm not a
superhero and I know I am
right so if someone told you that you
couldn't sell companies and do the
things that you did because to them it's
superhero [ __ ] it's a dream that they
can't come true for them
you feel me like you've done things that
people want to do
and I guarantee you if you came with
that idea that certain people they'd say
give you 30 reasons why you can't do it
the reason why Rockefeller was good the
reason why I did what I had to do was
because I knew how to have a clear dream
without anyone obstructing it I knew how
to visualize winning
so if somebody told me you can't do that
because of this get out my dream because
that's not the last thought I'm gonna
have with my dream because my mind is
powerful and whatever I see in my mind I
can make happen so what I'm living in is
my dream
I dreamed about coming to London right
now
in the past
this was a visualization I didn't know
exactly what I'd be doing in London but
I visualized doing a lot of [ __ ]
talking to a lot of people
you understand what I'm saying so if you
can't visualize winning then you will
not win
and the average person because we're
programmed not to win 99 of us are
we don't think anyone can so when
someone does it's amazing but it's just
a program as soon as you're born you
know I've said this before you don't
know about fear what to be scared of
until someone tells you what to be
scared of
and a lot of what people tell you to be
scared of is to actually be successful
and dream and be independent and be on
your own
you know what would you like if you were
a conniving person that wanted to take
over the whole world and you had that
kind of power but that you had to
program everybody the first thing I
would do is take everybody's kids as
soon as they wake up and program them
for eight hours a day on what I want
them to do I want you to go to college I
want you to get a job I want you to work
until you're 70. I want you to be
unhappy I want you to have a a debt I
want you to go get a loan to go to
college and then I want you to work that
off and if you don't if you don't go to
college then you make it you you make
your parents dreams into a nightmare
most kids only go to college for their
parents
you understand what I'm saying then you
pay for that
so when I look at hieroglyphics I never
see school I think parents love their
children the most no one's going to love
their kids more than the people that
made them those should be the people
teaching them
why would you put a kid in a in a in a
room
behind a desk when the sun is out
for their whole entire childhood
not put them in front of water or Ocean
or anything that inspires them dim
lights if you notice schools jails and
hospitals all look exactly the same
why wouldn't it be in something
inspiring
why
because it's a program to keep us
controlled
you have to when you have to have order
of masses you have to have them all
doing the same thing so you can know
what they're doing you can monetize what
they're doing you know how they're doing
it
so at a very early age I was like yo all
this [ __ ] y'all teaching me first of all
none of it makes me think I'm number one
it would make me if I believe that y'all
are teaching me especially back then
that I'm number two that I could never
be a boss that there could never be a
black president
they never teach us how to pass laws and
and Lobby or be politicians and that's
the only way to make change
so it has to be strategic so when the
cycle continues over and over again
without change it's either insanity or
it's intentional
somebody's losing which is us but
somebody's winning which is them
and they're controlling the game
so now we have to make our own game
which behooves US
but the patterns that are implemented
like you said the DNA of who you are
starts when you're a child
what happens as soon as you're four or
five years old until you get taught what
to read how to read what to do and
you're also told that the only way you
could break a social class is to be an
athlete or be an entertainment and both
are provided for you in school so you
just cash out and don't go to school get
an education you go and invest all your
dreams in being an athlete which is like
lotto and when it doesn't happen they
build a jail based on those that don't
graduate
that's how they build jail cells which
is a independent sector
with me you know meaning that you know
it's out you know it's not the
government doesn't own it and the
intention is to keep those beds and
those jails filled because you have a
government contract it's nothing but a
hotel that you want to keep so when you
get to that jail based on the fact that
you didn't get your education they make
sure that you come back no
Rehabilitation at all and serve you bad
food no therapy none of that [ __ ] and
it's obvious if you study people which
people do that you should do that
different so that there would be a
different result
but because there hasn't been any change
made by anyone
the change has to come from us
and that's the reason why Rockefeller
was successful because I wasn't with
none of that
not the education not the programming
that we should be signed none of that
[ __ ] not them telling me Jay was too old
all of that
you understand what I'm saying so
basically everything I've been told has
not behooved me
but everything I do has
so when I don't listen my family eats
when I do we don't
one of the things they don't teach us
when we're we're young is about is about
money especially if you don't come from
it and you haven't got a and that's a
business holding money is a business
within itself they don't teach you how
to pay taxes yeah they don't teach you
about
um capital gains yeah they don't teach
you about trust funds
none of that [ __ ]
they don't teach you how to have money
because they don't expect you to get
none
why isn't there a class on how to have
money
how to invest it how to pay your taxes
yeah I mean I destroyed by 18 years old
we have this thing called a credit score
out here I think you have the same sort
of thing in the US I destroyed mine very
early and then I got these two ccjs
which is a county court judgment which
sits on your credit score for six years
when I was 18 because I was shoplifting
pizzas I was my parents weren't speaking
to me I was trying to start these
businesses how do you shoplift the pizza
you just walk in you get back just as
smart as you can so they don't you're
still black so they're still going to
look at you walking in the shop but
you're just as smart as you can go
around the back put it in the bag walk
out that's what I was doing I just
didn't have any money
but um but I I didn't I destroyed my
financial his my financial credit before
I knew what it was but it didn't bother
you because you still did what you had
to do I was convinced I was going to
make a million Millions anyway so in the
street there is no credit there's no
contracts
your word is your contract your honor is
and if you come from that like that's
the way I was introduced to life
was the honor not the contract
not the paper but the heart and the soul
you know and that's another reason why I
was like yo I can't be a businessman
because it means my honor game is out
the window
how did you learn those lessons of
business you start Rockefeller but you
haven't gone to business school selling
drugs huh
you got to Market you got to be
consistent you know you got to call it
top no one else can use that color you
protect it you brand your work got to be
good marketing man well that's it wasn't
see that's the thing about hustling this
is another thing it's like because it's
illegal you can't do no ads you just got
to put out you got to give samples out
and once the work once they addicted
then you raise the prices
for the marketing of Rockefeller that
was something it was just the brand we
were just active bro you know like
innately I don't know I look back at
tapes that I have of like you know when
I was like 19 like and I had merch but I
didn't call it merch back the things I
was doing I didn't get taught I didn't
have a title for them but it was just
logical to do
you know if you deal with logic as
opposed to waiting for somebody to tell
you I mean that's the difference between
being a soldier and a general
soldiers get they wait literally to be
told what to do
generals give orders
there as well the naivety seems to be
playing into your favor because if you'd
gone to business school and learned
about how to build a
a record like while I was in business
school I'd have been missing building
bro I paid for my daughter's college
right
but I told her you don't have to go to
college she wanted to be a model at the
time
those four years it would have been the
prime years far
you understand what I'm saying now she
graduated
and it's like
I I would have preferred because her
Education costs a quarter of a million
dollars I would have way preferred to
just give her a quarter million dollars
as a salary or at least invest a quarter
million dollars in the business fund
you know I tell my son lucky he's in
college right now and I'm telling him
I'm like I just did this with your
sister if I'm paying for college you're
going to listen to your professor but
you're gonna have to listen to me too
I have to be able to now this is my
first lesson tell me what your dreams
are
what's your dream and it's the hardest
question for him to answer
they don't teach dreaming in school
which is why we make books that aren't
going to be mad about it I'm part of
something called the OSG
and there's also and it's a 200
principles and most of these principles
are from places where
um most people are economically
challenged
and what we do is we discuss curriculum
the things of board of education's not
doing we'll do it they do that on
Thursdays and on Tuesdays I teach the
principles and entrepreneurial class
because none of the principals knew how
to dream I'm like how y'all teaching
your teachers to teach the kids how to
dream if y'all don't so in order to
teach these kids how to be Fearless
y'all got to be fearless and they have
and they've been there so I'm not just
the person that talks about problems I'm
actively trying to fix them I read that
point about dreaming I've heard you talk
about visualization and dreaming and the
importance that plays and I've also saw
you on a on an interview before you
asked I think it was the host the guy
that said he wanted to be an actor you
are yeah yeah you remember I thought
that was brilliant I watched it last
night and he's you know what's the right
type of dream to set the one that you
love what inspires you but don't dream
cheap because they don't cost a dollar
you gotta dream big why would you dream
small
pause you know what I mean
like why wouldn't you have the perfect
best case scenario and it has to be a
selfish dream because you can't help
nobody unless you can help yourself
period unless you're 100
you can't help someone else be 100 have
you always had a really crazy dream in
your head yeah I've been living it
Rockefeller was a crazy dream in my head
but so was dd172
you know what I'm saying these other Art
Gallery everything I'm doing right now
being a director you know what I do is
like as a creative person
I like look at my life like a movie and
I like to play different characters so I
got to play the gangster character early
got that out the way
I got to be a a music mobile years ago
a fashion designer fashion mobile
you know I started oil I sold oil for
fun you know just to do it
you know web three metaverse the
galleries you know with network you know
that's where I got my land and network
because of the utilities that it could
do it could do a lot of [ __ ] just
playing these different roles where does
Focus come into this because this is
none I'm insane I don't have any Focus
that's the problem
if there is a problem that is it
I drive my staff and my crew crazy
every day there's a new idea I'm
inspired and I want to make it happen
tangible or it bothers me
and I have the wherewithal to make it
happen I'm a starving artist but
starving is relative for me
you know
imma always have a staff that can make
my dreams come true so while I'm in
London trust me the Third Edition of the
magazine is being right as we speak and
right now I can feel it actually being
drawn and written you know
what I came to learn probably the hard
way about this point of focus is like I
have all these dreams and things I want
to do but they all come at the cost of
the things I'm currently doing because
it's 24 hours a day even my my team's
time is finite so if you're well aware
that um focus is an issue for you and
that you know you can't do everything
how do you how have you not sort of
stops range yourself in a little bit
with all these ideas and projects you
have going on because as I said I read
the list and I was like Jesus sometimes
I have to like completely detach
so
the last three months I just left la
I've been trying to stay away from
creative things I've been hiding my
cameras from me
you understand what I mean I'm staying
away from people that inspire me I'm
telling you you know I mean I'm in the
house looking at a lake me and my girl
and my baby for the last couple of years
maybe I'd say nine to ten
I've just been a creative and I've been
creating
and I haven't been outside I haven't
been trying to promote or do any of
those things but I have so many tangible
physical assets Goods that need to be
sold right now that it's time to be
great so I've proven to myself that I
can be an artist now I need to prove to
myself I can make money off being an
artist why does that matter so I could
pay the bills so I can make more art
to be able to have every single thing
physically that everyone that sold out
has is important to me so people could
know they could do it on their own
so if you see that Dane did it and I'm
like a regular guy
to me besides the superhero [ __ ] but if
I could do it most people believe that
they can as well so it's important to
lead by example
you know a lot of people give these like
classes and they're standing third I'll
be like yo just look at what I'm doing
I'm not talking about like as I'm
talking I'm like I don't make a living
from talking
I make a living from actually talking
about the things I'm doing but the
living comes from the things I'm doing
you understand what I'm saying like I
got [ __ ] I'm doing like I'm not just I
got a movie to show you right now three
I got a magazine to show you right now I
got a comic book to show you right now I
got a children's book to show you right
now you know what I mean I got a whole
fat I got so many different fashion
lines you know you know I have an album
out right now camera on me camera on the
a track it's called you wasn't there was
number one on the rap charts last week
I forgot I put that [ __ ] up
when is enough enough work fine it's
never enough fun
if I'm not again it's not like I got a
bunch of bread you know what I'm saying
if I had crazy bread then they'd be like
oh you I'm not doing it for the money I
just do it every single day there's just
new [ __ ] to do you said before we
started recording you you're busy in
your mind almost to the the point of
insanity and when I spoke to rock who's
your fiance fiance she said you're
crazy crazy motivated the most driven
motivated person she's ever encountered
in her life he just never turns off he
doesn't sleep
I mean how sustainable is that how
sustainable has it been you tell me you
tell me I'm 51 52. I'm chilling almost
to the point of insanity though he
doesn't turn off he doesn't sleep I'm
just having so much fun
it's not like I'm like I don't leave her
though it's not like I don't leave I I
don't leave the house I'm up working so
it's like oh [ __ ] it's music to make you
know or oh [ __ ] there's a movie to make
you know this is so much to do and I'm
having mad fun so my dream like when I'm
like literally like physically when I go
to sleep and dream at night my life is
better than anything I could be dreaming
about and I get I'd be like like
literally I wake up like I'm glad I am
to stay in that like um is this am I
still in my house like you know I mean
like I I love if God listen for me not
to take advantage of all the opportunity
that God has given me based on where I'm
from
it would be disrespectful to the
opportunities that are presented for me
to sleep right now
it'll be disrespectful it's too much
like I I am very aware that I live a
privileged life compared to most people
because I can actually do things based
on Art all day
so it just would be disrespectful to art
you know if you if I was coming up right
so say I hadn't done anything in my life
and I was young kid 18 years old and I'm
saying dang I've got all these ideas
you know I've got this book comic books
the TV the movie did a
what advice would you give me in terms
of I'd say Focus interesting but the
thing about it is the difference is when
I say I have all these ideas I'm also
showing you tangible things can you
execute people have ideas all day not
many people can execute I can see that's
where there's a gift in the curse
because I can finish because I actually
can do it
because I will do it you understand what
I'm saying yes isn't it yeah
but I love it the reason I'm really
obsessing about this topic is I've I've
been talking to my team some of them
seems like it must be a similar
relatable problem and that's exactly why
I'm really picking at it because you
know I don't worry about it we're told
that we can't move in 10 different
dimensions at one time but we really
can't but what about 20
you could do 50. but then it comes at
the cost of one of those and that's what
I've been contending because life
doesn't come with a cost
so I'll give you an example this podcast
here we could start multiple podcasts
with loads of different creators should
do it but even five percent of my time
thinking about that problem was taken
from like my company let me show you let
me equate that too
so
there are people that can cook very well
for their family
but a real Chef has to cook a thousand
plates
every [ __ ] night
he does not do that on his own he has
other chefs that he teaches
so that's part of being a business
person like look at Walt Disney
like look at Disney they do a bunch of
[ __ ]
to insanity but it gets done
so that's where the business comes see
I'm lucky enough that I can understand
my left and right side of the brain but
I kind of understand if you do two
things both of them working at the same
time
doesn't work out because in when you're
dealing with money you can't be
emotional
but when you're dealing with art it's
pure emotion
so when I'm shooting movies and people
try to make me do business I'd be mad
like get the [ __ ] don't you
it's not going to come from a
businessman's plate it's going to come
from an emotional place
so you know
identifying when to turn off turn on
It's Tricky have you ever over extended
yourself in terms of taking on too much
and don't [ __ ] I need to always
hmm
like you gotta remember like I don't
have no support
it's all me
financially so all these things that got
made got made from one pocket
you know what I'm saying an independent
pocket
so it ain't there's never no money to
look at like I'm always
racing a storm
when things happen to me in life it's
like what's the message here right so we
get we had this crib in Florida
first two weeks lightning hit the crib
blew out the [ __ ] air conditioners
and you can't be in Florida without air
conditioners in the summer
and then this hurricane comes through
so the hurricane is on his way
I gotta go to the black caucus in
Washington I have a commission meeting
and do a panel for the congressman Andre
Carson an account in the commission
and I'm like yo I'm not going to be able
to fly out of any Florida so we go to
Hilton Head we got a crib in Hilton Head
and Rocky's parents are from Hilton Head
so we go to Hilton Head
six hours away
the storm comes to Hilton Head I got to
go to Washington so while the storm is
coming to is getting ready to go in the
direction I gotta time it because we
can't fly so luckily I'm you know
because I'm able to move around I got a
sprinter gotta driver I'm like yo I'ma
drive there it's only eight hours away
but the hurricanes come through it might
catch you how many hours I got three all
right let's go we yeah the wind is
catching us we got to get you know what
I mean but that's what my life is like I
felt no fear
which was crazy
you know what I'm saying it was like fun
and what was crazy about it wasn't a
paid gig
now if it was a paid gig I wouldn't have
went but because I made a commitment
because the commission is important to
me and the congressman through a
commission dinner in the middle of Black
Caucus and you know he also
had a panel for me to speak on and
before covet I was supposed to speak on
the panel and I missed my flight because
of traffic so I was like I can't do that
to him again
you know what I mean
so I was like damn you'll go out in a
hurricane for something you believe in
and for honor and for money I'd have
been like [ __ ] the money you know what
I'm saying I know I would
but my point is my life is like that
it's it's like it's always close
you know I mean and I don't mind it
quick one as you might know crafted one
of the sponsors of this podcast and
crafted are a jewelry brand and they
make really meaningful pieces of jewelry
and this piece by crafted when I put it
on for me it represents courage it
represents ambition it represents being
calm and loving and respectful and
nurturing while also being the
antithesis of that seemingly the
antithesis of that which is
um sometimes a little bit aggressive
with my goals and determined and
courageous and brave the really
wonderful thing about crafted jewelry is
it's super affordable it looks amazing
the pieces hold tremendous meaning and
they are really well made quick word
from one of our sponsors I've got a tip
for all of you that will make your
virtual meeting experiences I think 10
times better as some of you may know by
now Blue Jeans by Verizon offers
seamless high quality video conferencing
but the reason why I use blue jeans
versus other video conferencing tools is
because of immersion their tools make
you feel more connected to the employees
or customers you're trying to engage
with and now they're launching one of
their biggest feature enhancements to
impact virtual events so far called Blue
Jean Studio I actually used it the other
day I did a virtual event using the
studio which I think about 700 of you
came to TV level production quality all
done by one person with very little
technical experience on a laptop so if
you've got an event coming up and you're
thinking about doing it virtually check
out blue jean studio now let me know
what you think because I genuinely
believe I know this is an advert and I'm
supposed to say this but I genuinely
believe it's the best tool I've seen for
doing really immersive simple but high
quality production virtual events one of
the things that your fiance said to said
to my team when we spoke to her was was
that you value that and loyalty
exceptionally High
it's everything
I could just tell you this where I'm
from survival is honor so if you don't
play the game right you end up dead or
in jail period and you have to play the
game right
unspoken laws
just honor
and I just always looked at people that
were honorable and how cool it looks to
be honorable how fly it is because
Honor's not convenient
you know it's when it's something that's
challenging and it's something that you
don't want to do but you do it anyway
because of Honor give me an example of
what you mean when you say honor what is
that in the streets what is it in
business too now being a man of your
work
so if you agree to something
that's it
period is he in the street if you give
your word for what a real streak dude
that's it you got to give it you know
what I mean like you can't like talk to
certain people and say you're gonna do
something that you're not they're coming
looking for you you said you gonna do it
you got to do it when I agree to do
something even I don't even care about
the money it's the your word you lie to
me your ass is out you're a race to me
because
that could get you killed that could get
you put in jail
those are characteristics of people that
unhonorable means you're going to tell
on somebody
to get yourself out of trouble
that doesn't usually deserve it
I was watching an interview earlier on
with with Kanye and he speaks incredibly
highly of you in all of and every time
he's asked I was actually more compelled
by you know you're heavily credited for
sort of discovering Kanye and seeing
something in him again like Jay-Z at a
time when no one else did Kanye has
become this this brand now and again
he's stretches across multiple
Industries in an unbelievable way in
culture and art in fact all these things
he's up on my wall upstairs I've
actually got a big a painting from his
his show where he had that levitating
stage but what did you see in him back
then
that you know to be responsible for the
the the monolith that he is today
what was it about him what made him
different
he would listen
Kanye listened
like
if I said yo have cameras with you he
had cameras with you
when he broke his jaw and and I I had to
send him that the equipment
and with that Through the Wire with his
jaw broke
if I I remember bringing him to London
I'd be like yo
rap He just jump on the table and rap
you know and and
the thing about
when you say I discovered Kanye yeah
but I gave everyone in Rockefeller the
same exact opportunity I fought like I
fought for Kanye and protected Kanye I
did that for every single artist he just
chose to do and take the opportunity and
the protection
and run with it until he didn't need any
more
and no one else did
what is his Brilliance and your
assessment
then he's so confident in his dreams
that they happen period
but but what job might not realize
about Kanye
and I'll probably leave it that way I'm
is that my personal experience with him
just watching him move around
is that he's completely committed to
what he's giving you
every single second until he passes out
he's working
he doesn't have a personal life that
I've seen every second is devoted to art
and it's it's in his hand it's Insanity
as well you know he said it he's like yo
I'm Dame Dash with a whole lot of money
and he is but you know the thing is he
has a whole lot of money because he
talks and works with corporate but look
how it triggers
you know what I mean so what it means is
no matter how much money you make
if there's still somebody impeding on
your art
you're going to be unhappy
and that's why my advice is always to do
it on your own
just for the happiness value of it [ __ ]
the money
if we all said forget the money we'd
make so much more
probably not in the short time though
right but in the meantime you're having
mad fun
when you're working on your dream money
doesn't matter
if you really truly love what you're
doing if you're doing it for the love of
the art you ain't really worried about
the money in that moment as long as you
can continue to do it
there's a trade-off though isn't that
I've experienced that my life and it's
kind of what you were speaking to there
it's the business side of you that keeps
talking because you still love money me
yeah I do love money to be fair that's
why you're conflicted yeah and I've
taken I think I've taken investment in
all the companies not these days but
yeah the last 10 years it doesn't sound
like it gets you uninspired
but that's why when you we spoke offline
and you said I quit my job I was like
didn't you just say you sold a company
how could you still call it a job yeah
so I saw that this is a job it's not fun
no more
I don't got a job
when you look at these people say in can
you you know case I don't want to talk
about him be on this point but um
obviously it's made him a billionaire
the trade-off you're speaking to is that
you know he's had these frictions with
the corporations and stuff like that but
puts him in a position now where he can
as he is doing go It Alone be an
independent
all I'm saying is regardless of what it
ends up in war
so if you get either way either you have
to walk away from your company or go to
war
one of the two
correct yeah most of the time
yeah if you look at I mean look at Steve
Jobs with no look at you he got fired
from happening let's talk about you yeah
yeah so it sounds to me like you've got
went public and got uninspired yeah lost
control
is that you gave away your control for
money yeah why would you give your free
think about this right
so when
slavery became in America illegal
everyone that had slaves were still
lawmakers that used to have slaves they
still were passing laws so can you
imagine this conversation yo what are we
going to do now we don't have slaves
well we have to make it where they are
slaves but they don't know it how do we
do that well let's suppress them and
let's make them fight each other
so every time one kills we get one kill
and then one goes to jail we get two for
one plus they all have kids they have
kids so now they don't have parents
they're disenfranchised so now the kids
do the same exact thing because they
have nobody to lead them
you understand what I'm saying
it's just the plan
to make us think we're winning when
we're losing but what we really do is we
give away our freedom so what happens is
you commit a crime you hurt your brother
and now legally you're in Chains you're
put in a cage and you're working for
slave wages
and now
instead of slave master
or Master is Warden or Co or at least
that's what we call them in in the
states I don't know what they call like
a it's called correction officer CEO or
Warden whoever runs the jail
it's a plan so they always trick us into
giving away our freedom by dangling a
bag the bag though because sometimes
it's man-made
money is man-made
the value of money is made based on what
a man says but real currency is love and
that's God made
so why would you listen just logically
to man telling you that his currency is
more powerful than God's currency which
is love
I'm going with God's currency every time
just because it's logical
and that's another thing logically
I just believe God has to be a woman
why
can you create life
but God creates life
can a woman create life
so what would be the closest thing to
God
the creator of life would be a woman
but of course a man because they have
muscle would trick the rest of the world
into believing that man would be if if
War
and people fighting
is the least smartest thing in the world
to do and that's men do that all day
it's the most destructive thing to do is
bad for business but it's good for
someone else's whoever's selling bullets
you understand what I'm saying and men
do this all day
so if you know men been running this
[ __ ] for a while and [ __ ] is [ __ ] up
I would love to see what life looks like
what women want to thinks I would love
that
the host end of your career the
Rockefeller chapter
do you have any regrets surrounding that
when you look back and think I wish I'd
done that differently I wish someone had
told me this thing that's Rockefeller
that [ __ ] is art why would I want to
mess with that
look how it's impacted the world
you know what I mean like yeah it'll be
things certain things that just because
I know better I do different
but who cares man I was like a kid what
are those things if you're giving me I
wouldn't I wouldn't have been so
generous with Jake to Jake
it was more friendship for me and money
for him
and I always felt that but I ignored it
a little you regret ignoring that I
don't regret it I just I wouldn't have
the things that I wouldn't have let
certain things happen because I didn't
think they could happen you know what
I'm saying like oh he would never do
that but he did things that I thought he
would never do so now I would be like oh
he would do that and I would make sure
it didn't happen
so Rockefeller would probably still
exist right now
I made those mistakes too
it is what it is actually
the life that I got after Rockefeller
was so [ __ ] it's been so fulfilling
and I've had so much fun
you know I just opened up art galleries
all over the world and made music with
cool people and I just I just been doing
cool [ __ ] for the last 10 years I was I
wasn't compelled by the uh what you said
earlier and you said Rockefeller would
still exist
yeah okay you tell me what was the in
the Rockefeller and why it happened
uh from what I understand and again this
is just what I've read there was a
dinner that took place between you and
Jay where Jay wanted to sell Rockefeller
to Def Jam no that's not where okay
there you go we had we we met at dinner
because I had heard from LA Reid that
Jay was like I'll take the job of
president but Damon and Biggs can't be
down with Rockefeller and LA Reid was
like yo and I thought John McNeely had
said this [ __ ] I like Jay could have
never said that and we went and he did
me like public place the whole [ __ ] and
told me this [ __ ] and I I was just like
[ __ ] serious Jay told you though he
said yeah I want to be looked at as a
businessman and as long as you're around
I can't be looked at as a businessman
but I was like what's that gotta do a
Rockefeller so he was like yo y'all
could have Rockefeller but just give me
my Reasonable Doubt Masters back I said
let me think about
and I went and did a screening of The
Woodsman and I was like yo come with me
to the screening so he could walk the
carpet he's like nah you're all dressed
up and I was like
Snicker never helps
but my point is regardless of what
Rockefeller still existed
it's just I didn't run it
so why isn't there still a Rockefeller
Rockefeller was sold right Jay was they
gave Jake it was sold but they gave Jay
to run Rockefeller
so Kanye was still there everybody was
still there why is there no more
Rockefeller
you tell me well usually when a rapper
runs other rappers it doesn't happen it
doesn't work no more it just means there
was no Rockefeller unless I run it
that's it
so I would have continued to run it
I wouldn't have put that you know I'd
dealt with it different and how when
you're going forward and like well I
didn't want to run Rockefeller no more I
was done with that I was at that time I
was already at rockware my office was
not I wasn't [ __ ] with music no more
and real quick was making a lot of money
right yeah but it was just more I was
just inspired I was just sick of being
in that building and dealing with dumb
[ __ ] I was done with the music business
I wanted to do fashion
I just I was done with it so I looked at
it as an out like out of obligation I
would have still ran Rockefeller because
I gave my commitment but because they
was acting silly I was like yo take it I
want to go anyway
you know what I'm saying
but you know how did you feel towards
Jay-Z now
I don't feel nothing
no
no bad feelings no good feelings
no feelings
I deal with feelings and they would
probably not be so complimentary
he's obviously achieved you know
tremendous success in all he's done in
multi-industries and all that kind of
thing
what is what is it about him that you
think has put him in that position his
characteristics I don't want to talk
about Jake you don't want to talk about
him not really
like you know I know what Rockefeller
was and how we did business so it's hard
to I I don't even try to figure that
[ __ ] out
okay you have a really unique
perspective in the sense that you you
know yourself Kanye J you got to see the
the characteristics that made them go on
their Journeys and that's really what I
was trying to get at is like what are
those the difference between Jay and
Kanye and I say it Jay is about the
money period and Kanye
is about the art and the money but it's
the art you know what I mean like like
like Kanye is a real artist
that Kanye is in different dimensions
like you know he's he really focuses on
that fashion
I never saw Jay do that ever not nothing
there
and he really focuses on his creative
like he produces his own beats
and then he's about like sonically he's
really into how things are like like I
don't even understand what the [ __ ] he's
doing when he makes Beats you know what
I mean like I know what it beats sound
but then he does some other [ __ ] that
makes it like where other people
respected you know he has it's an art to
what he does
and um Kanye obviously has opinions
you know he's not trying to fit in
so Kanye's whole thing is I don't give a
[ __ ]
you know he's an artist that likes War
but most artists I don't know I think if
you will it's like art is something that
you really fight for if you love it
even if your message is misunderstood
like white lives matter
yeah I don't understand it you don't
understand his message there no Kanye
holla at me bro explain that one too
I didn't understand that one either I
did try and read after I saw his post
but I still couldn't quite grasp
grasp what he was actually don't holler
at me I don't want to talk about that
yeah the only reason why I would want to
talk to him so I could know so I could
protect him
that's the only reason why but other
than that it's like
yeah that one went that one there I love
cognac
seems to have bothered you seems to have
bothered you that one
no
nothing he does bothers me I've learned
I know about Kanye you know I know that
his thing is to trigger so he's a
trigger so if I'm not going to be
triggered you know what I'm saying like
he likes that [ __ ] I don't
that ain't me I mean you know I it's fun
to watch but certain things I'd be like
but sir you know like I said we we have
a relationship where if I don't agree
with him we have conversations
you feel me and that might be why
sometimes we don't speak for a while but
you know what I'm saying like with
everyone that I love
I'm not going to just say things are all
right if they're not I'm gonna tell you
my perspective on and sometimes people
don't want to hear that [ __ ]
I don't I don't know what's going on so
I can't judge it but I wouldn't have did
that [ __ ] you know what I'm saying I
didn't like it
but I'm saying I'm telling you right now
but I'm not gonna disown them but I
didn't like it he's like that person in
in Thanksgiving that Uncle that you are
like I have think about it like you know
Stacy I have Stacy Dash at my [ __ ]
Thanksgiving table
imagine what that would be like
it [ __ ] the elephant in the room gets
addressed you understand what I'm saying
but that be the reason why a lot of
times it doesn't happen so often because
I'm always adjusting not not because I'm
you know I just honestly would like to
know curiosity
what did you learn from how Rockefeller
came to end about business life people
I didn't look at the music I didn't look
at that as business that's why I was
like it's not they're not it's not real
business
so you got to think about I'm gonna like
at that time I'm a real businessman that
means I want to be strategic I want to
make plans if nobody wants to do that
[ __ ] and I'm doing it on my own it
becomes very frustrating so I had to
fight for Rocawear you know what I'm
saying I had to do it on my own I had to
fight for Rockefeller I had to do it on
my own
I was just too much fighting and then
fighting for the fighting with the
people that I'm fighting for it just was
you know it was just like I'm not
fighting for a bunch of dudes like it's
just you can't get there's nothing to
get from it's a game so just like yo
it's a bunch of ungrateful dudes
and I can't have my daughters around
these dudes
you know all right do you have trust
issues in business yeah
there's no trust issues I trust no one
another drink
same yes please we can just keep talking
it's okay isn't it yeah it's cool we can
just keep talking yeah
you said you got you got you don't trust
anybody
do you
yeah cool
um my girlfriend
[Laughter]
you think if you make her really mad you
think she's gonna you trust that she's
gonna be fair
what do you mean if you do something
unfair yeah Will her reaction be fair
yeah I trust my I mean I trust my girl
but I trust Jack
oh Jack
well how much you trust him he has your
bank account numbers and [ __ ] I'd give
him my bank account numbers he would
yeah
my assistant Sophie I trust her as well
my brother runs his Works full-time for
my company Jason I trust it he actually
manages all my finances my bank account
all my Investment Portfolio when I do
shark tank Dragon's Den we'll see how
that works out it's going well so far we
don't you know no no no no I'm just
saying this let me just say this
of course I have people around me
and everyone has to deal with those
things
but the trust thing is I'm cut from a
certain kind of cloth
so what may not be honorable to people
because they're not from the same
experience as me
it may be different version than what I
see
so I don't trust that people look at
things exactly the way I do
like some people don't think things that
are disrespectful are because they're
not a boss
you understand what I mean like if
you're not a person that's actually
paid people
for service if you've never done that
which a lot of people have not that
judge me which I don't care
then you can never ever understand what
it is to pay someone and then not do
their job you just never know what that
is so you don't trust people
nah
people don't even trust themselves
there's no one in your life that you
trust
your fiance no I I mean there's a level
of trust yeah
yeah I mean I trust I trust her
yeah that's right I trust my girl
but people you know I don't like family
it's like whatever if they [ __ ] you over
they do it is what it is you know that's
that's their bird in the bear you know
what I mean like karmically but people
that I don't have to trust I don't
like there's always like I trust people
like
yeah but there's there's never 100 you
know it'll be like you never know what
someone's doing when you're not looking
bro
people are different
you know when you're a person that's
cutting the checks it's hard to trust
people because they're just showing you
what they have to show you to get the
money
you feel me you know I was saying this I
was you know being in Florida
you understand real racism like
[ __ ] is racist out there you
know I mean like broke [ __ ] too
the crazy [ __ ] about like racism is like
being a wealthy
or what could appear to be a wealthy
black man with a staff
and you might get someone from another
culture and they'll be like but you're
still not white no matter how much money
you got I don't want to be white you
know what I'm saying but they still have
that chip like but you know it's got one
thing that's like I'm not trying to be
that you think that's what it is I don't
you feel what I'm saying but what I
understood is I've never had to feel
racism because I'm always the person
that's hiring and firing people a racist
is never going to act like a racist in
front of me
he'll get fired
or worse
you know what I'm saying but if you're a
person that's not in that position you
have to deal with racism imagine someone
that's racist your boss
and that's a lot of people
so the only way to really combat racism
is economic empowerment you have to
either own the bricks you have to be the
boss and then you select the people that
you want around you
and if they want to be racist they
better internalize that and go get some
therapy because a black man is telling
you what to do
on that point of the people you have
around you how do you pick those people
what are you looking for when you're
hiring somebody or you're looking for
someone to partner with what
characteristics are you looking for they
got to be the best at what they do that
I need to hire them for
and I prefer a certain kind of
discipline what kind of discipline
that every hour of the day that you work
and that you love what you do you know
that you that you respect my time and my
money
but you know it's just really at this
point
like when you're looking to invest in
somebody you look at potential
but when I'm hiring somebody now their
potential has had to have already
realized itself because I'm paying it's
like a professional team
so there's favors there's certain
relationships that I have that are
completely personal
and I work with you because we have a
personal relationship I'll help you
that's personal
but when I'm really paying you you just
got to be at this point you need to be
the best at what you do so I'm gonna
look at your work
you know what I mean I just need to see
your work I need to see what you've done
before you work with me
how like so if I hire a DP I need to see
they real what do you think about
pessimism and people you're working with
because I've seen from watching your
interviews that you seem to have a real
problem with people that I hate negative
people
if you're negative you got to get away
from me
and there are people that come negative
pause because that's just what they've
been raised but they're skilled and it
hasn't worked out because of that
because it's just like you just lead
with negative First
you know if the first thing if I have an
idea the first thing you want to talk
about is the problems with it then we
got an issue there's a time to talk
about problems but not while I'm
dreaming
and hard work you know in our culture
there's been a bit of a I guess a bit of
a movement around hard work that you
know work-life balance and these kind of
conversations what do you think about
work-life balance and the importance of
hard work and achieving Big Dreams
hard work is everything
and
if you look at the people you know this
is misconception
that black people can only have black
people work for them you know what I
mean
like you know in the U.S more so than
here probably yeah and that's where I'm
coming from that's the PTSD web yeah so
you know what I find is I'm not trying
to only hire my culture because I I know
my culture I know my culture
I'm trying to take over the whole world
so I'm gonna have Benetton and I have
been like it's black white Chinese every
kind of person in my in my crew because
I want to speak every language
I don't want to be wrong I don't want to
be good for somebody black
it's time to be good for being I'm the
best human I'm going at everybody
and
there's also this thing where
you know it's always like black people
should only have education for black
people
and I think there should be new
education for black and white people
there just needs to be no education it
needs for us to figure out how to come
together as a human race
because it's been strategic that we've
for the last hundred years we've been
saying the black thing
always it's always separation
which gives fear
which is what causes racism
but I just believe if we're at least the
landlords and we can make a curricula
that everyone can [ __ ] with just us make
it it's just about us being the ones to
make the [ __ ] I believe it would be good
for everybody
no fear because you know we're not
worried about
someone else and them taking over what
it looks like we already know what it
looks like
you know what I mean to be like yo let's
keep everybody happy as long as this
division is nothing gets done and again
that's another thing that I I feel is
strategic
so when I make a movie I'm not like yo
this movie's for black people I'm like
this [ __ ] for everybody this ain't just
good for black people this is my [ __ ]
better than everybody's [ __ ]
you feel me I'm not just trying to
educate us I'm trying to educate
everybody because if we're the only one
educated then we really gonna have a big
fight because once we get an enlightened
and people acting stupid we ain't gonna
have it so we have to evolve everyone
you understand what I mean it was
everyone needs to catch up we're all
human
forget to pass so much learn from it but
let's talk about how to move forward in
the future collectively
you mentioned at the start of this
conversation that you went and had
therapy to understand yourself a little
bit and to understand your triggers and
what was triggering you and where that
came from what age did that happen
well being a child like myself I was
always put in therapy no matter what but
I didn't talk
um but as I got older like when Aaliyah
died I just always was looking at it
like I might need a consultant that
didn't have a dog in the fight to tell
me if my actions were right or wrong or
to give me advice sort of like a
consularity but what I understand about
therapy is black people don't get it so
the study of therapy doesn't come from
our trauma it comes from other people so
when we finally do get this in the wrong
language so we have to find therapists
that actually speak our language that
come from similar traumas unless they're
not to talk to us so that's why I have a
program called healing this gangster Taj
he's also in the commission is a
therapist that's been through everything
if not more
and now is actually a doc guided
Doctrine and he's a therapist you know
what I mean and that's the person I talk
to daily
like any time that I'm unsure about how
to react to certain things
the times I'm the most unsure is with my
children and that's when I call him but
then you know I had to fight to even be
able to see my daughters
so I had to go to court order therapy
and I learned a lot there about how to
raise my daughters so the difference
between 25 year old Damon and 50 year
old Damon 25 year old Damon would have
thought because I Boogie I was a single
father no one ever talks about that
um he went to court and got him but I
used to bring him into my environment
and thought that was fathering but with
a child you have to go to your child's
environment and I need a therapy to
actually show me that how much better it
is for me to become a seven-year-old
than for my seven-year-old they have to
become a 50 year old
you understand what I'm saying and be in
a place that they don't care about see
the things that you care about as an
adult your kids don't care about
just think about what you cared about at
certain ages
so you'd be like oh but you know you
don't care none of my kids care about
any famous people they don't even know
them until they get older
they don't care about anything that I
have because that's all they know it's
not like a big deal it's not like a
comparison like they're not in another
you know life where they're you know
some social class below and then they're
like oh you know I mean it's just what
they know they just want time and they
want you to do what they're doing and
they want you to speak in their language
and that's what I've learned that's why
I've made all of these with my girl for
my son she's made children's books and
syllabuses from the womb to three years
old and all this programming on how to
interact with your child
you understand what I'm saying so I'm a
way better parent now
which is most important
what was the hardest moment in your life
when when my mom's died when Aaliyah
died
when people die that's the [ __ ] that's
the hardest but everything else is easy
when I read about um well obviously
remember the news the global news when
Alia died but when I read about it
before you came here now that I'm in a
relationship with someone that I love
um I I tried to play out well I played
out in my head what that would feel like
don't do it yeah I just couldn't I
couldn't get there my brain wouldn't let
me go though
it's a it's a pain that you know
couldn't understand
but surviving that pain has made me very
cool
what was that period of your life like
it was sad
but you know things were going on so it
was like me it was me organizing my
self to still be strong because when
people see that you're weak they attack
and people are actually getting cute
it was it was me proving to myself that
I'm a real General
that I I could work with a broken heart
is there a cost to that always being
strong
nah
I'm not saying that I didn't feel
I'm just saying I had to learn how I had
to lead by example so in that moment I
was like the way I react to this is how
every single person that looks up to me
is going to react when they lose someone
they love
you understand what I mean
and you know being at you know when when
you're running or you're the you know
not to say when when you're the head
and you're a lot of different people
are depending on your strength it's a
life I've chosen
you feel me
so
when you choose to be a certain way or
take a certain role
like I would rather do that than sit
around and be sad you know what I'm
saying like I don't want to sit around
and be sad you know for me it's like
life I have so much fun
that when natural tragedies happen when
things happen that are going to happen
to people just you know a matter of when
I can't let that [ __ ] up my fun
it's just a test
but you know it takes reading
and and therapy
to organize to be able to move at a
professional level
but you know your five children
if they had to be successful and happy
that in their lives what are the what
lessons are you imparting on them to set
them up for success and happiness you
know the thing is the the people that
are the hardest to talk to are my
children
you know
but
I think my daughter Ava
who's been through every you know as a
youngster have been through the wars and
all that but like where she is now
I really feel good about my parenting
skills
because she knows what happiness is
and
she's just so she just loves the family
so much
I don't really think that way with my
children you know I mean it's just like
I just want them to be happy
and I just feel like it's my job to make
sure that they're happy
but if they don't find it on their own
anything about children when you have
children
is after certain age they're not
children no more so you could be like I
got children I don't have five kids I
have like three adults you know what I'm
saying or at least two
but they're still my kids so if they're
not happy
then I want to make sure they are if
their dreams like my job is to make my
kids dreams come true
but they have to know what they are
do your kids know what their dreams are
nah it's a conversation I have often
with them
and I'd be having like yo write it down
they don't even listen to me I'll be
like
should I get paid to save they don't
listen to for free you know
but they're still perfect to me
you know it's hard because
the good part thing about like baby
dusko my son is that Rocky is instilling
everything that I'm instilling there's
no contradictions like if I say
something she's not saying I'm wrong so
there's no choice it has to be made
we're both instilling the same thing so
I'm curious to see how that one's going
to work out
all my kids are different
all of them
you visualize you visualize for your
whole life I was I was reading about how
when you were building Rockefeller you
would pull up at houses and go and view
houses that you knew you couldn't afford
because one day you need to be able to
afford them and this this sort of thread
of visualization I still did it really
still pulling up our houses
yeah but I could always buy them but I
promise you once I go look at a house
and I want it I figure it out
my question is like what are you what
are you visualizing now you talked about
living in that neighborhood where people
sold out but what is what is Dame's
right now I'm as far as business or
personal both personal I'm visualizing
like 100 acres
having a farm in a studio and just
frolicking you know
but having a private jet you know what I
mean and maybe it's in Hawaii you know
that's
there's a lot of things there business
is turning game Dash studios into what I
call like a Disney you know
you know visualizing buying schools
going into marketplaces where
you know they might think it's
dilapidated and taking a something a
building that's messed up and turning it
into something creative and bringing
kids in there and teaching them
you know there's a couple of laws on
visualizing passing or getting passed
I'm visualizing what our culture looks
like in the web 3 space
getting past the monkeys
you know
and making it more about creativities
and not some static you know I'm saying
that's not creative that could have
you know racial implications and
connotations
with all these things going on you still
said earlier that you feel like you're
behind schedule in your life's roadmap
yeah if you were on schedule what would
that look like all those things would be
true all of those things would have been
realized all of those dreams
yeah
it's crazy because
I think what I'm most bothered about is
the fashion business for me
because you know I did a lot with Rachel
and then like it's like we flushed that
one down the toilet and I really love
fashion so I I I I I think the next
thing that I want to get back in fashion
and also my age like I'm 50
and I've always wondered like what I
would look like fashion wise at 50
because you know Styles change and I'm
not trendy I'm more like I'm kind of but
not really you feel me
and a lot of the people that I've molded
or at least that I worked with when they
were younger are now doing very well in
fashion
so I'm like
I always like the fashion world that was
always my favorite world
so I gotta get back I think I want to
get back into fashion
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the Lost guest asks a
question for the next guest they don't
know who they're asking it for so and I
don't get to see it until open the book
the question that's been left for you is
what are you most missing
in your life it actually says what are
you missing most in your life
right now
I've been missing my children
because they're all doing their own
thing and I can't never get them all at
one time
you know I mean like I gotta get like a
day a couple times a year that all my
kids like I'm always with three at a
time or two I never have them all in the
same house
I'm missing that I'm missing my
daughter's
a lot because I've been on the road
I'm mentally here
I'm always curious like if Alia and
Rocky knew each other what that would
look like you know what I'm saying
because I see so much of like Rocky has
a lot of similarities to Aaliyah that
people would not even understand
um you still miss her yeah
yeah
she's she was the coolest like you know
unless you were able to experience so
you could it'd be hard for you to
understand
she she was she still is she was magic
but again
the type of magic she is it was like
when I could I never thought I'd see
that magic again but I saw it in Raquel
in a very unsuspecting place
which was odd
but yeah she was different and you know
to me
like in history I think she'll go down
is probably
the coolest woman singer coolest
of all time and when she was alive she
was like had that aura of coolness of
being the coolest
and she told me I was the coolest you
feel me so you know
what does your life look like how do you
feel about yourself when Aaliyah tells
you that you're the coolest
and Aaliyah you understand thank you you
understand what I'm saying what kind of
confidence do you have what kind of
validation do you have when you could
really be like
Aaliyah told me I was the coolest person
she ever met
a lot of people have told me that what
Aaliyah told me that
I'm so inspired I've been really
inspired by so many things you've said
but really the the dedication to Art and
being an artist I think is something
that people don't speak about enough
because everyone's trying to get the bag
and business and build but the art is
obviously where the emotion the love and
the expression the bag has always been a
distraction
money is the devil bro
makes you forget everything that makes
you happy
there's no way to get both at the same
time yeah be all right be artists I'm
doing it
I just told you it comes with a fight
but like you're an artist right
a DJ I write books I have a musical that
tours the country that's my art that's
the piece of me where I go I'm doing
this for money and it doesn't if we make
money we give the money to charity is
that when you're having your most fun
yeah 100 I mean
exactly so why not make money off what
makes you the happiest yeah that's a
good point
usually because you don't have
confidence in the fact that you could
but that's what I decided to do I have
complete confidence in my Artistry I
just want to make money off me
I'll help people get money but first and
foremost
I gotta be about me
thank you thank you for your time thanks
for coming here you're someone that I've
I've admired from a far for many many
years from an art perspective a business
perspective and I've watched your videos
and your your mindset I think is the
thing that I that I think everybody can
take the most from because the mindset
and your mindset really is like a
fishing rod it's like a way to maneuver
life in order to orientate yourself
towards success and good outcomes Dame
thank you quick one it's so crazy that
in the last couple of months I've had so
many people tag me on Instagram even on
Telegram and in my Twitter DMs in a
picture of them starting their heal
journey and it's one of the most amazing
things in my life that I get to do a
podcast which of course needs money to
to fuel and I have a sponsor like Hill
who I genuinely believe is going to help
every single person who starts their
heel Journey change their life because
this podcast the central intention of
this podcast is to help people live
better lives it gives me my protein it
gives me my vitamins minerals it's
plant-based it's low in sugar
gluten-free it does all of that in a
small drink that tastes good there are
other products there's Foods there's the
hot and savory collection many other
things but for me this ready to drink is
the absolute savior of my diet
throughout the week where I'm moving at
such Pace look I don't want to labor the
point but if you haven't tried he'll
give it a try and if you do tag me
Instagram wherever you try it give me a
tag
[Music]
this is
[Music]